you know why and welcome to this video
playing group that's Grand Master seem
an actor Stein the check former coach of
mangas cars and longtime number one of
Norway so we have a scotch game okay I
don't really know this kind of line
night be three have a good score against
him though two wins and just one draw I
just have a soft spot for those for
those maneuver isn't that and it's
already already striking I can take f2
let's see night f2 rock chicks check
check again windstar house right why
doesn't that win I don't see it I think
it should win
check
mmm I have a double check 1 e 2 on f3
it's that's for a moment let's think for
a mold if there is a checkmate I don't
see it at the moment but now i can take
tons of pieces here yeah like this it
will definitely be a piece up at the end
like if i take here I'm two pieces up
all night f2 should also win this is
probably the easiest check
there's still two pieces hanging so i
should actually emerged with with an
extra one resides yeah so the quickie
queen edge for struck again let's see a
4 is 6 yeah I think this is really good
it's a it's just activating like yeah
and tonight f6 is already tricky that's
tricky the engine gives h3 and he has to
he has to probably 94 is a threat I go
here and threatening this already here
it's a big initiative this is what the
engine used now taking here check this
work I can do this however it's very
comfortable already but yeah this is
losing I think yeah i'm just-just
winning stuff maybe the best chance to
fight is actually to give the exchange
here like this and just hope for a
miracle now here can I'm just winning
winning the house and there is no no
maid or anything but it's it's a rock
it's a full book currently and I'm both
threatening to take here and here so he
has no no trick available okay and while
the quick win against me mr. arctor
Stein thanks for watching